Young people have earned a reputation for
taking down industries and institutions,
from Applebee's to breakfast cereal. And
although many of these critiques are
exaggerated, the effect that young people
have had on organized religion is indisputable.
More than four-in-ten young people
are religiously unaffiliated today.
It is the most common
religious identity among young adults.
And a new survey suggests that these
religious changes may be permanent.
And here's a couple of reasons why: First,
young people today were raised in less
religious homes. Growing up, they were
less likely to attend religious services,
say grace over dinner,
or go to Sunday school. The young adults
who've left their childhood religion are also
leaving early — mostly during adolescence.
In fact, 70% report having become religiously
unaffiliated before they turned 18.
So, a 30-year old who is unaffiliated
today has likely been that way for
over a decade. Finally, due to the
rise of online dating and the sheer
number of secular romantic partners,
secular couples have now become more
common, reinforcing secular identity and beliefs.
Did you have a religious
upbringing? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.